when you watch your typical disney movie
you usually don't think about real-life
colombian wars impostor syndrome or deep
intergenerational trauma but encanto
isn't your typical disney movie there's
a lot more to the film's ending than you
might think
when each modrical child receives their
gift the house creates a room just for
them so even though bruno left the
family his room is still there earlier
in the film after seeing cracks form in
the house that then patched themselves
mirabelle entered bruno's room in an
effort to find answers while mirabelle
finds glowing shards of etched glass
showing a vision of her and the family's
crumbling home in his room she doesn't
find bruno and therefore has no idea how
to interpret the image later while
walking along a corridor of the house
mirabelle notices a picture on the wall
is crooked and when she looks behind it
she finds a hole she enters and finds
none other than bruno instead of leaving
the family as the madrigals assumed
bruno has spent years living within the
walls of the house and between the
isolation and the challenges that came
with his ability to see the future he
comes across as a little odd
bruno explains he disappeared after he
saw the unnerving vision of mirabelle in
the crumbling house adding that the
vision kept changing and he couldn't
figure out what was really going to
happen
given the unfinished nature of bruno's
vision mirabelle asks him to look into
her future again
needing more space antonio who recently
received his gift of talking to animals
offers his new giant animal-filled room
for their purposes shortly afterward we
see bruno and mirabelle sitting together
in a clearing and bruno is using his
power for the first time in years
bruno takes mirabelle's hand so she can
see what he sees and soon he's brought
her to the vision of her future depicted
in the image she found
however he pushes past that point to a
vision of mirabelle hugging her older
sister isabella which seems to heal the
family's problems mirabelle finds a
vision perplexing though since she and
isabella don't get along
while mirabelle isn't thrilled with the
idea she's willing to do what it takes
to help her family so she seeks out
isabella with the intention of hugging
her as bruno's vision dictates
earlier mirabelle ruined a dinner at
which local hunk mariano was supposed to
propose to isabella so when mirabelle
tries to get that hug isabella responds
by yelling at mirabelle for destroying
her moment
but then isabella concedes she was only
willing to marry mariano because abuela
alma approved of the match she admits
she spent her whole life being as
perfect as possible for the good of the
family suppressing whole parts of
herself in the process
as isabella yells she sprouts flowers
until her anger reaches its apex and she
creates a cactus
she's delighted by her prickly and
imperfect creation and it makes her
wonder what else she can do with her
powers if she doesn't have to be perfect
she and mirabella sing what else can i
do as isabella further celebrates the
joys of embracing her true self
as isabella's song ends and she and
mirabelle arrive in the courtyard of the
modrical's house abuela alma is there to
greet them
isabella has spent the entirety of her
song exploring the limits of her powers
which means she created plants that
aren't beautiful but are a fuller
expression of who she really is
this has caused her to make a mess of
her dress and hair turning them from put
together perfection to a colorful
hodgepodge and abuela is furious to see
it
yet mirabelle ends up bearing the brunt
of abuela's ire when she once again
tries to express her concerns about the
magic in the house flickering out the
madrigal's gifts and their magical
houses powered by a candle that abuela
prayed to during her flight from her
original home 50 years ago in the time
since the candle has never gone out and
the magical miracle has become the
source of the madrigal's identity in the
community
so instead of taking her concerns
seriously abuela is angered by
mirabelle's repeated suggestions that
the candle could go out and the magic
could die abuela and mirabelle argue
fiercely and as they do
more cracks start to appear in the
foundation of the house to the
astonishment and horror of everyone in
the family
as a crack splits the ground between
granddaughter and grandmother mirabelle
springs into action the house starts to
crumble as mirabelle climbs to the open
window where the madrigal family's
magical candle sits the rest of the
family saves one another from falling
debris and runs from the house just as
mirabelle reaches the candle
only to find that for the first time it
has melted to a tiny husk
when the dust clears and the house is
nothing more than a pile of rubble
mirabelle is nowhere to be found
the family especially mirabelle's mother
and father don't know where she went and
spread out into the nearby mountains and
forest in the hopes of finding her
ultimately it's abuela alma who
discovers mirabelle sitting by the side
of a river that she hasn't gone near
since she arrived in their current home
half a century ago
now that the worst has come to pass
abuela's anger has dissipated but
mirabella is still hurt and defeated
abuela reveals that the river mirabella
sitting beside is where mirabelle's
grandfather abuela's husband pedro died
while trying to defend her and their
children from the people that forced
them to leave their original home
after the collapse of their house abuela
has come to realize she's been holding
on too tight to the family's miracle she
was so traumatized by the loss of her
husband that the idea of anything else
bad happening especially the loss of
another family member has caused her to
see the family's gifts as a lifeline
it's why she hasn't been able to
appreciate everything mirabelle has to
offer and she sees her children and
other grandchildren through the lens of
their gifts but abuela is finally seeing
clearly and she and mirabelle reconcile
as they do so bruno rides up on a horse
he's worried that abuela is still angry
with mirabelle and tries to take the
blame for what happened to the house but
abuela is no longer concerned with the
signing blame and simply embraces her
long-lost son
abuela bruno and mirabelle make their
way back to the site of their former
house
as the only madrigal who isn't magical
mirabelle tells them they can rebuild
and as the song all of you begins
mirabelle reassures the group that
they're more than their gifts they can
all contribute to the construction of
their new house without any magic as the
family sings and bruno apologizes and
makes amends with the siblings
everyone in the town approaches
the people who would always relied on
the madrigals for leadership assistance
and protection have come to offer their
help to rebuild the family's home
the family and their neighbors work as a
team and as they build the house
together with maribel in the lead the
madrigals each learn to embrace who they
are beyond their gifts
with the house rebuilt and the madrigals
prepared to celebrate their triumph over
tragedy they hand mirabelle a specially
designed doorknob as the family
encourages her
she puts it in its place in the front
door and lets everyone into their newly
constructed home with the foundation of
the modrical home restored the candle
reignites and the family members once
again have each of their gifts
so
what does all that really mean
encanto was never specific about the
event that forced abuela alma and her
young family from their home 50 years
before the start of the movie however
there are plenty of clues that suggest
the movie is referencing a real
historical conflict the thousand days
war a civil war fought in colombia
between 1899 and 1902 the war pitted
conservatives against liberals who were
outraged after an 1898 presidential
election they expected was fraudulent
after the liberals were defeated in the
first phase of the war they resorted to
guerrilla tactics in rural areas for the
next two and a half years before finally
surrendering it's during this phase of
the war that abuela's family was
displaced and mirabelle's grandfather
was killed
and kanto never specifies whether abuela
alma supported the liberal or
conservative side given the chaotic
nature of the war it may have simply
been bad luck that led to her village
being caught up in the fighting
still the long-ago experience of being
forced to flee her home and seeing her
husband killed in front of her led
abuela to cling to the safety that her
new home and her family's gifts provide
when war came to their village abuela
alma had no choice but to leave a place
that based on the movie's depiction of
it had previously been a happy home for
her and her husband that experience
alone would be dramatic but the fact
that it also led to pedro's death meant
the deep pain abuela experienced was
even more overwhelming throughout the
film abuela talks up the miracle that
protected their family on that fateful
day and how it continues to benefit
their community still underneath her
positive exterior lies a well of trauma
that's impacted every member of the
madrigal clan leading to a family that's
suffering from all the signs and
symptoms of intergenerational trauma
even though mirabelle and the rest of
abuela's grandchildren didn't experience
the trauma that led the family to their
current home abuela's expectations and
attitudes have had an outsized impact on
them it's constraining the way they
behave and who they believe they can be
the madrigals each choose to cope
differently
mirabelle's flower-powered sister
isabella tries to live up to the
family's every expectation to the
detriment of her own wants and needs
strong sister louisa is riddled with
anxiety because she believes if she's
not helping the community she's
worthless
mirabelle spends most of her time
denying the fact that her lack of a gift
has left her scarred and uncertain
the trauma that is an inextricable part
of the madrigal's origin story has also
led some of the members of the family to
suffer from imposter syndrome while it's
possible others in the madrigal clan
have this issue the movie illustrates it
through the characters of isabella and
louisa each believes they may not be as
perfect or strong as the rest of their
family and the people in the community
believe they are this has caused them
both to overachieve which makes it
appear as though they're both happy and
successful in their roles in the town
however the songs both characters sing
in the movie indicate otherwise in her
song surface pressure luisa expresses
her concerns about failing to live up to
her strong image
a fear that drives her to tackle any
task as quickly and efficiently as
possible however while she acts like
she's comfortable doing so much work
inside her feelings of overwhelming
exhaustion leave her feeling weak
riddled with self-doubt and depressed
meanwhile isabella is the star of the
family and her place as the picture of
perfection has led her to continue to
try and keep up appearances
until she lets that control go in her
song what else can i do
she's secretly afraid her family and
neighbors will realize she's a lot
messier than they know
while encanto makes it clear that the
madrigal family has been dealing with
some big issues by the conclusion of the
film they begin to tackle the
intergenerational trauma that's impacted
all of them
they've also started the healing process
this is triggered when mirabelle seeks
out bruno forcing the family to talk
about him for the first time in a decade
while the conversation initially scares
many of the family members based on the
song we don't talk about bruno many of
them are also happy to finally let their
suppressed feelings about bruno out this
initially leads to greater turmoil in
the family but eventually it forces
abuela to recognize her children and
grandchildren have more to offer than
just their gifts when it comes to
intergenerational trauma an adjustment
by one member of the family impacts the
whole family abuela's change of heart
also makes the other family members see
that there's more to life than their
gifts as they rebuild their destroyed
house together they come to embrace
themselves and each other flaws and all
by becoming more open and accepting the
madrigals start to move past their
trauma and become a happier healthier
family
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
disney movies are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]